Imagine if you could gather the energy for every style within 100 million light
years from thousands of galaxies,
each with billions of stars,
and imagine you could take this kind of power and use it to find the biggest
super weapon in the universe.
Imagine the damage you could do.
It turns out you don't need to imagine it.
These exist and they're called gamma ray bursts,
but what are these cosmic snipers and what happens if one takes a shot at earth
to understand gamma ray bursts?
We first have to understand gamma rays.
Gamma rays are electromagnetic radiation waves,
which carry energy just like visible night.
Visible light is a tiny part of the electromagnetic spectrum.
It's the part your eyes can see at lower energies.
There are radio waves,
microwaves,
and infrared,
and at higher energies,
ultraviolet x rays and gamma rays.
Gamma rays are incredibly powerful.
A single gamma ray photon is more energetic than a million of visible photons
combined.
They're high energy,
makes gum arrays a form of ionizing radiation,
meaning they are energetic enough to break apart atomic bonds.
This makes them dangerous to you and me.
Ionizing radiation disrupts the delicate biochemical machinery that keeps us
alive like a nine millimeter bullet through o'clock.
Fortunately on earth,
the ozone layer blocks gamma rays filtering them out before they can harm us,
but if the atmosphere blocks gum raise from space,
how were gallery bursts or grps from space ever discovered during the Cold War,
the USA sent up spy satellites,
which could detect gamma rays from Soviet nuclear tests in space.
They didn't see any bombs,
but they did observe faint bursts coming from space lasting only a few seconds
to date.
This may be the only major scientific discovery made by spy satellites that we
know about.
Anyway,
astronomers use telescopes that see different kinds of light to make that
discoveries and the spy satellites gave them a new pair of eyes.
They were a mystery for 30 years,
but eventually we discovered the source of a Grb,
a galaxy 6 billion light years away effort.
GRB can be seen from such a distance that it must be incredibly energetic,
releasing more energy in a second,
then the son will and its entire 10 billion year lifetime making GLBS the
brightest events in the universe.
So where do they come from?
GLBS accompany some of the most violent cataclysmic deaths in the universe and
the birth of black holes.
There are two types of gamma.
Ray burst short and long and each has their own source.
Long GRB lost about a minute and scientists think they are produced by
Supernova.
When the core of a massive star collapses to become a black hole.
Short grps lasts a second and are produced when two neutron stars in a binary
merge over millions of years.
They're all bits decay by emitting gravitational waves.
Once they're close enough to touch,
they crash and splash into each other,
forming a black hole.
Both supernova and neutron star mergers make the same thing.
Black holes surrounded by a magnetized disc of gas leftover from their parents.
Stars in these environments,
the rotation winds up the magnetic field,
which funnels hot gents of particles traveling at Navy.
The speed of light.
The gas in this funnel create two tight jets of high energy gamma rays like a
celestial days a gun.
So unlike other cosmic explosions which spread out and fade GRBC stay focused
and can be seen from much further,
any more detail would require too much mathematics.
For a youtube video,
the universe is full of these cosmic snipers firing blindly and randomly into
the dark and they're hitting us all the time.
On average,
we detect one per day.
Fortunately,
most are harmless.
All the bursts we have detected so far originated outside the Milky Way too far
away to hurt us,
but a nearby GRB could be disastrous if one goes off within a few light years of
us,
it would totally cook the surface of the earth or at least the half that's
facing it,
but even a more distant GRB could still end life on earth and it wouldn't need
to score a headshot to get us.
If originating from a few thousand light years away,
it would be a hundred light years wide.
By the time it reaches us,
washing over the soda system like a tidal wave.
Again,
the ozone layer protects us,
but it's better equipped to handle the trickle of ultra from the sun.
A gamma ray burst would overwhelm,
is leading US exposed to deadly solar radiation.
Ozone takes years to replenish itself by natural processes,
which is more than enough time for the sun to burn the earth sterile or at least
to kill most complex life.
In fact,
this may have already happened.
A DRB has been suggested as one possible cause of the Ordovician extinction 450
million years ago.
The dedicated almost 85% of all marine species,
although it's pretty much impossible to prove gamma ray bursts could even be one
reason we don't see life anywhere else in the universe.
They might be wiping clean huge chunks of it on a regular basis.
It's been suggested that because of Grps,
only 10% of organic says might be hospitable to life similar to us.
So are they going to kill us?
Probably not.
In a galaxy like ours,
there may only be one GRB per millennia and to harmless,
they must be close and directed at us.
But since gamma rays travel at the speed of light,
we weren't.
No one has headed our way until it arrives.
So there could already be a GRB on its way to kill us all and we won't know
until it hits us and we're debt.
This video was sponsored by squarespace.com/nutshell death from the sky could
come around any second,
maybe even now.
So you don't have any time to waste.
You don't need to set up a website.
Portfolio or blog is usually hard and time consuming,
not so with Squarespace though they let you set up a page with easily
understandable tools very quickly and without any knowledge of Web design you
can use the code nutshell to save 10% and support courts.
Cozart Squarespace had been a great sponsor so give them some love.
You can support us directly yet patrion or get coats cause onto march hare.
It really helps.
Over the next few months,
we'd like to make more videos about cataclysmic destructive events because
honestly,
it's a lot of fun to make these.
If you have any ideas about what kind of doomsday scenario you'd like to learn
about,
let us know in the comments and if you need to kill a little more time.
Now,
here are a few related videos or maybe now.